Ian wrote in hey David lots of people go
out of their way to appear smart in
social situations which I actually don't
think as something smart people do
is there something people do in social
situations
that actually makes you think they're
smart yeah this is an interesting
question I've never met really smart
people who deliberately try to make
themselves appear to be super smart in
fact it's usually the opposite and what
I mean is the following if you're really
really smart in my experience in social
situations you do way more asking of
questions than you do talking about your
credentials or intelligence or
accomplishments
smart people that I've met tend to be
very comfortable saying I don't know
enough about what you're talking about
to give you my opinion whereas the
people who were not so smart but really
want to seem that way are very quick to
give you whatever they believe their
expert opinion is on absolutely any
issue I think that actually recognizing
that you don't know things and being
comfortable in social social situations
to say that that's not your area of
expertise you'd like to learn more that
to me signals that you actually are more
intelligent person ignorance is
intelligent it's like 1984 over here
ignorance is not bliss but rather it is
intelligence no and and again it's not
ignorant I got yeah just but it's just
attractive to say that I don't know much
about this issue right it's attractive I
think it's well it's like it's
intellectually curious at the very least
I think it's it draws upon you and
that's almost honest for sure if someone
is capable of abstract or hypothetical
or rhetorical thinking when talking
about something that to me signals
intelligence which interestingly enough
have you noticed that Donald Trump is
not able to think abstractly he's not
able to speak abstractly he is only able
to speak in these short verb noun type
sentences he can say I am like a smart
person yeah I went to one of the best
schools in the country
where if it grades I am like , a smart
person is how he likes to say it the
other thing that to me translates
intelligence is when someone is able to
explain a concept to somebody else
particularly someone who might be
clueless about a topic
if you were able to take something that
you know a lot about and have really
advanced oh yeah definitely if it's
something that's that's a complex issue
and you're able to talk to someone who
has no knowledge of that and you're able
to come up with a way of explaining it
that the person with no knowledge
understands it or at least has an
opportunity to understand it I think
that that's a skill that really
intelligent people have which is very
interesting because the people that want
to often appear smart they will try to
explain things in the most complex way
because they think that makes them seem
really intelligent Wow I didn't
understand a word you said you must be
really really smart the actual smart
person will realize that they need to be
able to explain it more clearly or it
just shows maybe that they have poor
interpersonal skills perhaps more you
know you can ramble on with your
superior vocabulary and your in-depth
knowledge of the topic right not gonna
make it a very comfortable conversation
for anybody probably not and if you've
noticed our best interview guests have
been those who have been able to boil
down complex topics into indeed
something that our audience can
understand some of the worst interviews
and we were not going to name any names
have been interviews where the topic
could be really interesting but the
person is not able to talk about the
subject matter in a way that has broader
appeal and and is inclusive and in a
sense is actually exclusive some of my
thoughts send me your thoughts what are
things that actual smart people do in
social situations that you come away
thinking wow that's a really really
smart person we've got a great bonus
show for you today david pakman.com
slash membership to get access
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
get access and free 2018 calendars on
our website david pakman.com slash
calendar 18